we welcome luis castillo back to the
bump no strikeouts when he went three
and a third on opening day ravaged in
the first inning by the cardinals law of
averages says he will be brilliant today
and snap back to four see if he can
establish that change up against this
lineup be aggressive early with the
fastball ground ball right on back to
custody a lollipop toss
one up one down
that's a good start wilmer defoe switch
hitter
that's the touch and feel that
castillo needs
you get two strikes he goes to that
change up and it's devastating the run
on this baseball right here that's what
makes him
so good you can see him muffle that ball
with this grip and strike three on the
chain jump he's putting together a tough
and bad against the red right hander
here's the two two once more and he
grounds it weakly right to the shortstop
position where mike lustakis is standing
he gloves and throws out moran louise or
to one two three first against the
pirates
bottom half of the first inning chad
cool on the hill for the bucks chad cole
wants to build off his last start here's
the numbers from the pennsylvania
lottery three innings one hit two runs
the walks are what kind of hurt him but
he was able to compete joe if he can
come out today get that fast ball in the
zone utilize it a lot more he didn't use
it utilize enough last start i think
he's gonna have a really good start
against the road to maybe slow him down
tyler naquin seven ribs tonight ago
first pitch swing
left field evans leaps gone
we say stay high second career lead all
homer second in as many days for tyler
naked top of this lineup has been so
productive and so aggressive and
tyler naquin is just on fire right now
the effect that a nick castellanos has
on the other team is okay we have to
game plan against someone in this lineup
wilbur defoe longer throw on a skip gets
on by moran castellanos turns moran has
to eat it head first slide castellanos
in scoring position
ground ball to the right of
defoe at third base and makes the
transfer
it's a low throw to first base
once again heads up base running not
assuming the out castillanos hustles
down to first base
on the overthrow makes it in the second
and now the reds are a take away from a
two-nothing lead castianos vato mustakis
and senzel can join them as he walks to
push in a run
two
nothing
seven ribs five games the most in the
first five games of a career in
franchise history
in the air that could add to it
fowler angling in
makes the glove tag at third throwing no
chance sac fly rbi
bottle slides home three nothing reds
three nothing one out
that's cracked over third fair ball he
threads the chart mustache is through
third he scores the windmill is on for
senzel the throw in
relay eaton now sent to second and on
the lean farmers out
but he drives in a pair with a base
knock and it's five nothing reds
five nothing
red legs focusing on luis castillo and
there the strikeout delivery of luis
castillo three up three down
luis castillo the pitcher will lead
things off
castillo down on strikes to start
and cool
strikes out naquin
and they complete the strikeout
cool a much different look here in the
second inning
looking cool he picks apart the reds in
the second innings
striking out the side
he's got a chip on his shoulder about
him which is not a bad thing
and he's due he's over two he's reached
on two base error and struck out new
pitcher is chris stratton
first pitch blast to right polanco
homerun castellanos
did you say something about uh
elite hitters
in the league
elite hitters go opposite field with
power
his last nine played appearances with
men in scoring position
six hits
hit by pitch two sac flies
seven rbis
and he blasts that one
gets down misplayed by evans fono scores
senzel on his heels throw to second the
slide
out at second base
give him a single
and two ribbies
and the reds expand their lead as the
booze rain down
the castillo turns down dustin fowler
his fifth strikeout
he is cooking with gas eight nothing as
we stretch
tyler stevenson
this is high in the air deep right did
he get enough he did to nothing reds
tyler stevenson has his first home run
of 20-21 tyler stevenson seems to have
immunity to high velocity the harder you
throw it the further he hits it potent
power this reds team on flush display
and the punisher connects back to back
go the reds
well we talked about the breaking ball
and the split
like akinum was just sitting on it did
not miss it
eric gonzalez
comes to the plate
1-0 offering and a fly ball to right
going back is aquino toward the wall and
it's an opposite field grand slam
clear the deck
with an oppo cannonball
a four spot on the board against amir
garrett in the reds
eric gonzalez's first home run this
season is a granny
[Music]
that first inning was tough
but they showed fight and resolve
battle down the stretch
can garrett bounce back the same way
swinging of this strike three
back-to-back case he retires the last
three that he sees
and the high flying cincinnati reds
close their opening home stand at five
and one winners of five in a row